this is unbelievable we received a sexy
uh birthday message from a sports legend
for robin
oh no i'll give you a hint
he's a three-time three-time major
league baseball
all-star world series champion he's also
a
self-proclaimed master in the art of
[ __ ] eating
[Laughter]
you got to hear that he's the one who do
you need he's the one and only lenny
dykstra
here's the lady in bed with his shirt
off giving you a sexy message what oh
hey robin's lenny dykstra here i heard
it's your birthday
and you're spending it all alone in
quarantine robin it would be my honor if
my
tongue quartetine inside your [ __ ] and
robin
i'll even take my teeth out for you
happy birthday
dear robin you keep my dick
throbbing happy birthday to you
lenny is shirtless laying in bed he
certainly won't believe he was an
athlete
well all right he's gotten a little
older
all right he's got a little bit of titty
on him but who doesn't
did gary tell you what he did for my
birthday
no what do you do he got on cameo found
penn jillette
and penn jillette sent me a birthday
greeting
that's funny that's funny gary and gary
gave
him a bunch of information about me
and penn didn't get at all that he was
talking about me
oh that's great i'm here to wish you a
happy birthday
you have vincent bryce's ashes really
you actually have vincent price's
ashes and you get bored with men easily
who doesn't
bought a pool but can't swim i respect
that very much
i scored a high on the narcissism test
coffee enemas what's wrong with that i
haven't done that either
boy you have you've lived so much more
than i have
and you're probably so much younger than
i am too ordered three 800
bottles of wine and someone else's bill
see i don't drink wine so i don't know
but uh
that's a lot of money eight times three
someone could figure that out right
anyway anyway happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear rob and happy birthday to you
and what's that tell what's that oh yeah
tiller says
happy birthday robin love you boy you
sound interesting peace